mehr nachdenken mehr Eigenverantwortung
da sind wir ja gerade auch direkt bei
Ihnen im Thema jetzt mitten im Wahlkampf
gibt's natürlich viele Versprechungen
die man machen kostenlosen Nahverkehr
beispielsweise die sagen aber das das
ist genau der falschen Weg zum Thema
deswegen weil hier wird Wohlstand
erstmal abgeschöpft und dann wieder
umverteilt für alles mögliche und all
diese ganzen politischen Projekte wo
sich Politiker die eigentlich an den
fundamentalen Dingen wie wir gerade
gesehen haben versagen die nehmen sich
jetzt vor die Welt zu verbessern an
allen möglichen Enden sie versprechen
uns kostenlosen Nahverkehr kostenlose
Kitas kostenlos ich weiß was alles und
worum geht's dann letzten Endes wirklich
es geht eigentlich darum dass ein Teil
der Gesellschaft durch Leistung diese
ganzen Dinge erarbeiten muss zum
Beispiel Nahverkehr oder Kita wird er
nicht dadurch kostenlos dass der Staat
ist bezahlt sondern es bezahlt auch
nicht der Staat sondern jemand anderes
bezahlt ist ich muss es vorher jemandem
wegnehmen ich muss es jemandem wegnehmen
der vorher was geleistet hat
und was rechtfertigt das das
rechtfertigt sich aus dem
Mehrheitsprinzip mehr ist es nicht ja
und wenn ich den Menschen die etwas
leisten etwas wegnehme dann muss ich
letzten Endes auch die die etwas leisten
davon zu überzeugen dass das mit Maß und
Mitte passiert und dieses Maß und diese
Mitte haben wir längst verlassen weil
jeder Wahl Zyklus dazu führt dass die
Politiker um Mehrheiten zu gewinnen mit
anderen Worten um Stimmen zu kaufen und
nichts anderes ist es mehr abschöpfen
müssen ist die Steuerschraube irgendwann
ausgereizt kommt die schuldenschraube
und ist die schuldenschraube irgendwann
ausgereizt kommt die gelddruckschraube
und diese Zyklus ist ein letzten Endes
politischer Zyklus der führt uns vor die
Wand sie waren Unternehmensberater in
den großen Firmen BCG meckenzie Roland
Berger sagen Sie uns mal drei Punkte wo
sie sagen das können wir uns nicht mehr
leisten das muss weg also wir können uns
nicht mehr leisten ein bürokratieapparat
der sich nur noch mit sich selbst
beschäftigt wenn sie von den 14
Ministerien zehn abschaffen das merkt
kein Mensch
das gilt auch für die 99 Bundesbehörden
da gehe ich jede Wette ein wir können
uns nicht mehr leisten ein sozialapparat
der nicht die Bedürftigen nicht auf die
Bedürftigen hört sondern auf die lauten
also mit anderen Worten der die
Schwachen nicht vor den faulen schützt
das können wir uns auch nicht mehr
leisten und wir können uns nicht mehr
leisten das Sozialamt der Welt zu sein
wir müssen den Menschen da draußen
helfen aber wir müssen ihnen nicht
dadurch helfen dass wir in jede
Verantwortung abnehmen sondern indem wir
ihnen Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe geben also
mehr Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe sie haben
genickt Frau Lotte ich würde sagen ja
gute Einstellung so muss es ja auch sein
weil sonst kriegt man sich hier im Kreis
finde ich ne weniger öffentliche Hand
heißt aber vielleicht auch weniger für
Schulen weniger für Kitas die dann
schlechter ausgestattet sind natürlich
erstmal gut mehr im eigenen Geldbeutel
weil wenn wir das was wir was wir jetzt
machen tun dann ist eben für die
Kernaufgaben des Staates gar kein Geld
mehr da der Staat beschafft bist befasst
sich mit allen möglichen Dingen für ihr
nicht zuständig ist und die Dinge für
die zuständig ist vernachlässigter
darüber und das sind eben Schulen und
das ist die Verteidigungsfähigkeit des
Landes ist das ist Rechtsprechung
Rechtssicherheit und der Gleichnis gibt
kann Aufgaben des Staates die fühlt er
aber gar nicht mehr aus weil jeder
Politiker sich ein Hobby sucht jeder
Politiker sucht sich ein Hobby mit dem
man Karriere macht und dass sie nicht
die Kernaufgaben des Staates diese
nämlich langweilig und deswegen befährt
man sich lieber mit all den
Randbereichen und Schaufel das Geld in
die Randbereiche in alle möglichen
Bedürfnisse in alle möglichen meine wir
haben 200 gender Lehrstühle in diesem
Land die der Stadt und der Steuerzahler
finanziert ich werde das unsere
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit dass ich auf ganz
neue Höhen kommt also da muss man sich
Tomaten Kopf fassen was finanzieren wir
denn finanzieren wir lesen und schreiben
oder finanzieren wegen der Sprache also
sie sagen auch thematisch muss man da
Umdenken andere Schwerpunkte setzen
gleichzeitig soziale Marktwirtschaft hat
Deutschland eins stark gemacht da liegen
auch unsere Kern ja unsere Kernen
Energie
der Kern das ganze sehen Sie das ähnlich
oder glauben Sie es gibt ja so eine Art
Mittelweg die man entgegen könnte wir
sind das richtig formuliert gerade die
soziale Marktwirtschaft um die geht es
nur haben wir in den letzten Jahrzehnten
erlebt dass das was als soziale
Marktwirtschaft mal entstanden ist mit
einem scharfen Löffel ausgehöhlt wurde
und etwas Neues reingepackt wurde was
wir hier immer mehr erleben ist ein
patentalistischer übergriffiger
nanny-start der glaubt eben alle
Aufgaben übernehmen zu können die
eigentlich private in der Tat deutlich
besser können und das führt eben halt
automatisch welche Aufgaben kommen
nehmen Sie den gesamten Bereich der
Gesundheitsversorgung zum Beispiel ja
wir haben da einen riesigen Bereich bei
den gesetzlichen Krankenversicherungen
der einfach eins zu eins durchläuft an
die Pharmakonzerne ja nichts durch die
Frage ist was brauche ich denn
eigentlich davon wäre es nicht
vielleicht viele intelligenter wenn ich
selbst auch als der
gezwungenermaßen gesetzlich versichert
hatte direkt bei meinem Arzt erfahren
würde was der für die Leistung der mit
der anbietet bekommt was das ganze
kostet eine Idee ist schon Jahrzehnte
wird aber nicht umgesetzt warum wird sie
nicht umgesetzt weil unter anderem auch
natürlich ein großes Interesse der nach
wie vor hoch profitablen
Pharmaunternehmen besteht
beispielsweise als eine Thema dass sie
sehen was sind denn ihre Befürchtungen
wenn da jetzt nicht in Ihrem Sinne
gegengesteuert wird na gut wir haben ja
schon im Grunde genommen das Desaster
ordentlich angehört wir haben jetzt 10%
Inflation was bedeutet das bei einem
Geldvermögen der deutschen von 7
Billionen pro Jahr 700 Milliarden sich
in Luft auflösen an Kaufkraft das ist
beziehungsweise in zehn Jahren
programmiert wird durch die Inflation in
großen Stil da werden Ersparnisse in
ungeheuriger Menge aufgebraucht die
Leute merken es nur noch nicht weil das
sind Dinge die sie zurückgelegt haben
die sie jetzt noch gar nicht ausgegeben
dass sie Einkommen schon schrumpft ist
haben sie mitbekommen wir haben viel
tiefer gehendes Problem wir haben eine
Zerstörung der Lieferketten wir haben
eine Beschädigung der industriellen
Basis unseres Landes durch eine falsche
Energiepolitik deren Folgen wir noch
überhaupt nicht abschätzen können
welchen Anteil haben auch die Manager
daran viele Unternehmen waren dann jetzt
abgehen ins Ausland viele erwirtschaften
aber auch nur noch auf die Rendite hin
haben keine langfristigen Ziele mehr es
geht nur um eine schnellere Rendite die
Ziele muss man erreichen aber wirklich
langfristig wird nicht gedacht muss man
da nicht auch mal was sie gerade gesagt
haben widerspreche ich Manager sollen
auf Rendite hin wirtschaften und das
Ergebnis natürlich machen die Fehler
aber der Markt bestraft die in der Regel
sofort es sei denn sie hängen am
staatstropfen und da liegt der
Radieschen Großteil unserer Konzerne hat
sich nämlich so organisiert wieder stark
organisiert ist die Konzerne haben durch
das Aktienrecht dass wir uns gegeben
haben eine Entkoppelung von Eigentum und
Management und diese entkupplung von
Eigentum und Management führt dazu das
große Konzerne auf die große Bürokratie
funktioniert nicht mehr wie Unternehmen
die eigentlichen Unternehmen in diesem
Land sind nicht die großen Konzerne
sondern der Mittelstand und Chef eines
Konzerns werden sie nicht dadurch dass
sie unternehmerisch ticken sondern dass
sie keine Fehler machen mit anderen
Worten dass sie riesigen vermeiden mit
anderen Worten sind nicht
unternehmerisch tätig sind und solche
Konzerne die orientieren sich dann eben
auch nicht mehr an den Bedürfnissen ihre
Kunden sondern die orientieren sich an
der Lobbyarbeit beim hat und sehen zu
dass sie den Staat dazu bringen
irgendwelche Dinge zu machen die ihnen
dann zum Vorteil gereichen das heißt die
Konzerne sind sicher nicht unsere
Rettung der Mittelstand ist unsere
Rettung aber den müssen wir befreien von
den von der Knechtschaft der
Überregulierung schauen Sie wenn Sie zum
Beispiel so was wie das dsgvo nehmen
also dieses ganze Datenschutz Thema zu
berechtigt des Anliegen des
Datenschutzes ist aber man hat dadurch
adressiert dass man eine bürokratische
Glocke über den Mittelstand gestillt hat
besonders leidet immer wieder auch immer
wieder Thema hier in der Sendung Thema
dass wir auf jeden Fall auch noch mal
vertiefen